quando escutamos verdadeiramente o outro
dizemos sem muitas palavras mas com
muito conteúdo você é importante pra mim
desde a minha infância e adolescência
foi treinada naturalmente para isso
daí vem a minha paixão pela arte de
escutar ana maria minha mãe é minha
primeira grande treinadora com ela
cresci presenciando o seu exercício de
escutar mais do que falar escutar para
aprender a escutar para ajudar a minha
casa sempre foi um porto seguro para
muitas mulheres que precisavam desabafar
e minha mãe é referência de diálogo
escuta para muitas delas até hoje
um fato curioso é que na maioria das
vezes que chegava alguém para o desabafo
uma aparenta uma vizinha as panelas
sempre estavam no fogo e o comando que
eu recebi da minha mãe era touch desliga
as panelas que eu vou dar atenção a
fulana em um dos seus aniversários
uma senhora muito humilde escutada por
ela apresente ou com dois rolos de papel
higiênico
eu com aquela situação inusitada recebia
aquele comando de olhar que só as mães
sabem dar e que dizia touch fique quieta
não fale nada que depois eu te explico
mas nem foi preciso a senhora muito
humilde e constrangida diz ana eu
agradeço tanto ajuda que você me deu no
momento em que eu mais precisei eu
queria de alguma forma e agradecer
como eu não tenho dinheiro para comprar
nada eu trouxe o que eu tinha naquele
instante eu entendi que o desligar as
panelas da minha mãe a forma dela dizer
você é importante para mim eu vou lhe
dar atenção agora
hoje ao invés de ligar as panelas
o meu celular na sua personalidade
simples e sofisticada minha mãe sempre
deixava claro para algumas pessoas o que
conversarmos aqui ficará aqui
isso é uma forma de posicionamento e
proteção e também de como não fazer o
mal uso da escuta é e do que se escuta
em muitos casos também para a maioria
das mulheres que vão fazer suas
confidências
elas relatam casos desabafo sobre
violência emocional patrimonial física e
até de auto-sabotagem em meu segundo
grau hoje ensino médio eu ajudei a amiga
não cometer o suicídio de alguma forma
eu escutei o barulho atrás do seu
silêncio e o desespero atrás do seu
sorriso e com interesse e o sinal de sua
permissão eu perguntei 'você quer ajuda
eu estou aqui e vou ouvir eu soube que
depois terá no final entregou os
sedativos
eu soube que posteriormente ela fez
escolhas melhores para sua vida
outro caso foi de uma mulher uma cantora
internacional se transformou em minha
amiga ela recém chegado aqui é o brasil
diz que descobriu mãe de um filho
autista e isso pra ela foi um grande
desafio com ela vários momentos de fala
e escuta escuta e fala aconteceram
depois ela aceitou o filho voltou para
os palcos e hoje ajuda outras mães
autistas com a sua história
eu nunca deixei de praticar a
expectativa mesmo quando mais precisava
ser ouvida em qualquer lugar e trabalhos
por quais passei
isso me levou a ter sua atividade com
todos os tipos de cliente
as dez anos eu sou educadora social e
designer de interiores por formação
eu consigo entender desde os meus
primeiros trabalhos os desejos mais
abstratos e objetivos de cada um mas só
a partir do momento em que minha
necessidade de se sentir importante para
alguém foi maior do que minha
necessidade de ouvir eu compreendi o
poder transformador da escuta quando
isso aconteceu eu já era adulta e tinha
mudado meu status de solteiro para
casado e comecei a vivenciar situações
emocionais semelhantes àquelas das
mulheres executadas pela minha mãe é mãe
de um casal de filhos minha filha em seu
segundo dia de vida operou esôfago e
demorou para aprender a se alimentar
meu marido que na época passava por uma
situação muito delicada de saúde
larguei tudo e fui viver essa nova
configuração familiar e emocional como
aquelas mulheres sempre com meus pais me
ajudando
essa é minha mãe principalmente ela
sempre esteve comigo me ajudar em todos
os momentos
afinal a dor nos une
foram tempos difíceis em 2017 a minha
biografia participou da exposição
mulheres negras brasileiras presença e
poder em sunny na universidade situada
estadual de nova york em new pautz com o
objetivo de mostrar que somos mais do
que sensualidade carnaval
somos mulheres
bretas pensantes e atuantes naquilo que
quisermos ser e divulgando a exposição
eu dei muitas entrevistas participei de
muitos eventos e ao rever essas
entrevistas ao escutar eu percebi que
precisava ter mais coerência entre o que
eu falava e fazia então resolvi fazer
uma grande mudança em minha vida
decidi abandonar tudo aquilo que me
fazia mal
fiz novas escolhas
separei me mudei meu estado civil
novamente peso nome endereço e o estado
de espírito
agradeça universo feminino todo o
desafio que lhe foi proposto
cresci
estou mais forte com todas as
experiências anteriormente não
compreendidas
hoje eu tatiana touch brandão
sou consultor em desenvolvimento de
liderança
desenvolvo principalmente mulheres mas
por uma identificação natural
desenvolvo principalmente mulheres
pretas a conquistarem a conseguirem a se
conectarem com todas as suas
possibilidades e potencialidades e
brilho externo e interno
confesso que estou muito feliz mas muito
muito feliz com esta mulher que me
transformei e que batalho para manter
mas eu tenho a consciência que isso se
deve
a partir do momento em que eu compreendi
o barulho que morava no meu silêncio
eu me ouvir
eu escutei verdadeiramente e agir por
isso acredito que escutar transforma
para melhor o mundo e as pessoas
gratidão
[Aplausos]